Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Sarah, James, Kevin, Lily, Mark. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
This program started as Kevin's walk-home thought in the channel on the 9th: the schools that most need Alaska skills have the least ability to pay for them. So the program is a broker. Three parts.
One, a needs board where a teacher posts what they wish existed. Two, a builder pool of people with spare credits or skills who claim needs.
Three, a fallback credits pool we seed from Claude for Good and Campus grants for needs nobody claims.
Can you scroll up to the top of that section?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Sure — one sec.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Good point — let's do that.
The partnership angle: two districts already said they'd post needs if the board existed. Demand is real.
How do we keep the broker from turning traditional knowledge into a work order? A teacher posting 'build me a skill about local plants' could pull a community's knowledge into a build without consent.
Yep.
Good catch. Needs that touch TK get routed to James's community review before they're claimable. I'll wire that dependency in.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Yeah, exactly.
Right, that's what I meant.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
That's fair.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Just flagging that this touches district partnerships, so loop me in when it firms up.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
That's fair.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
That's fair.
Sure, I can own that.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That's fair.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Sorry, can you say that last part again? You cut out for a second.
Sure — one sec.
Let me park that and come back to it.
I'd want to see the routing rule written down, not just intended. What triggers the review — a keyword, a category, a human check?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Sure, I can own that.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Fair.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Good point — let's do that.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Right, that's what I meant.
Category plus a human check. I'll spec it. Kevin, can you get the two districts to pilot the needs board?
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
That's fair.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Good point — let's do that.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
That's fair.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Good point — let's do that.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Sure, I can own that.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Right, that's what I meant.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
That's fair.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Okay, works for me.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
That's fair.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Good point — let's do that.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Right, that's what I meant.
Okay, works for me.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Yes.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Okay, works for me.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the access needs-board and credits broker anyway.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Yeah, exactly.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Agreed.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Keep the platform dependency light — the needs board can be its own thing, it doesn't need to block the registry.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
How does this interact with the access needs-board and credits broker, if at all?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Agreed, let's capture it.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Sure, I can own that.
Okay.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Should I loop anyone else in on the the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync side, or is that covered?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Should I loop anyone else in on the community review and the advisory process side, or is that covered?
One thing: how does this affect the district partnerships timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Rachel has the follow-up on the access needs-board and credits broker — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Kevin has the follow-up on district partnerships — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.